what an interesting thing to do what
like a fascinating
i don't know if you call it experiment
because for you it's not an experiment
like it's your life
and it's it's been the real world's been
a huge part of your life for so long you
know i think about when
um it started and how there wasn't
anything like that before it you guys
had no idea
kind of what would become of tv after
you did this right
yeah we really had no idea um we really
i i thought and i think most of us
thought it was a like a little
documentary
on mtv on seven artists that would like
run for a summer because mtv was doing
music videos and little ducky things on
music artists and
and it was like cool we got our little
chance on mtv
because i was in music so i thought it
was great
and then after 13 weeks we were like
what is going
on you know like what is this
and it just became its own organism you
know it was its own thing
that just sort of morphed and then after
our show
it became reality tv our show actually
wasn't reality tv we were a docu-series
yeah yes yeah now you got
pretty emotional getting back in there
uh can you explain what it
how it felt what you felt walking back
in
well i didn't know i was gonna be at the
loft i i thought it was some
you know undisclosed location i thought
what is this and i had bothered
you know a production assistant about
i'm like come on tell me something he's
like
well it's a house and i thought that
that's weird in manhattan a house
i was like i just don't get it but
anyway we were walking along and they're
filling me going and i see broadway
the sign of broadway and i'm not
thinking anything and then i see
prince street and i'm like wait a minute
you know and then there was the
scaffolding right in front of me and i
was like
that scaffolding is still here after 30
years
that's crazy yeah it's very emotional i
just burst into tears they really caught
me
i was like damn because you never want
them to catch you crying or anything you
know
but they know how to do it right they
know they're really good at they're
better at it than barbara walters was
remember barbara back in the day she got
everyone to cry
but it it you know it must have played
such a big part in
sort of uh prompting you all
to get in back into the swing of not
necessarily the roles that you had
before but at least
the feeling of being in there the
feeling of being together like it was
before what was it like to actually get
back together after like 30 years
well we'd all seen each other off and on
throughout the years so
um not a lot i saw a lot of norman
because we ran in similar circles
for a while and um we just became good
friends and norman is everybody's friend
you know he's
really good at that um i hadn't seen
julie for 30 years
or was since the reunion in 1994 because
we just live different lives in
different parts of the country and it
just didn't ever
our paths never crossed and i'd seen
everybody else a few times
over the years so i wasn't and
andre i didn't see very much so to go
back to the loft with all of them in a
way
even though i hadn't seen a lot of them
over the years i felt we had this bond
we all felt feel that bond
you know having done it and gone through
it together and so going back to the
loft this time
to my surprise it was like regressing
in some ways back to 23 24 years old
and you're with your like old high
school friends
or college alumni and you just kind of
regress and all those same dynamics go
into play
yet it's like more intense because we
can't go outside because of a pandemic
there's social revolution people are
upset
there's cameras it was really really
pretty nuts i
i'm surprised we all did it yes well i
mean that was the that was the big
question i had i thought you know
it had changed your lives in so many
ways the first time around
so the idea of coming back to it like
was there hesitation
well yeah at first i thought absolutely
not i'm not gonna do that and then i
thought yes i am
and um and it was very interesting
because i
i wanted to see everybody and be
together it was an important time
in our lives and i thought this is it
was just timing it was like the right
thing to do
it's hard to explain it it was just i
thought that you know what i thought i
was
a little naive about it i thought that
we would be able to somehow make a
difference
that we would be able to go in with a
kind of maturity that other
reality shows wouldn't have or you know
and just being us
we'd be able to kind of communicate
because it's such a
it's a it's an upsetting time and an
interesting time it's a time of
transformation and i thought yeah
that's where we were before in 1992 and
now we're coming back and maybe we have
something wise to say
you know and also maybe just being
ourselves and being together
is going to be nice for people also to
take a break from everything that's
going on
you know to have some joy did you feel
like you
accomplished part of that like did you
feel like you had wise things to say i
mean you had just said that
you sort of regressed back to the way
that you were and truthfully like when
you get back together with people you
haven't seen a long time you
kind of do that naturally right yeah
like just gonna say like did you think
that the years
of like changing growth and maturity
affected the way that you were able to
sort of maybe get a message out this
time around
yeah i think that um
[Music]
i think that what i really wanted was
just for us to be together and to relate
as people
and the messages and the agendas and
the activism and so forth it has its
place
but at the same time everybody's
screaming from rooftops right now
everybody's on social media everybody's
lobbing grenades everyone is just has an
opinion
and i thought that the real message we
could have
is the human interaction you know of
just
um being together talking about things
being reasonable
being rational um having that kind of
interesting wisdom of being in a
generation that didn't grow up
taking pictures of ourselves and texting
to start relationships with people
you know it was all very imp very
personal
and i really wish that that had been the
case but it really did get as
dramatic and as in incendiary in some
areas as the first show
and um what can you do it happens
what do you what do you think that the
um
you know when the show was over the
first time around
the becky of you from that time like
when you were like back then what would
she think
of you coming back and doing this now
i think she would be surprised that this
is who i
who she became um only because
i think she was still figuring out who
she was
as a person and i think she would be
like are you nuts woman
what are you doing can't you see me
stress it out the first time around
you're going back when you're 53 years
old are you out of your mouth like why
did i become this person
you